[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
four 800-835-6747 now here's your host
from amazing facts international
pastor doug batchelor hi friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
in 1889 lake conomo was a picturesque
man-made lake in pennsylvania
over two miles long a mile wide and 60
feet deep at the dam
the pleasure lake was created to
accommodate the prestigious south fork
fishing and hunting club
which included such famed entrepreneurs
as andrew carnegie
in may of that year several days of
heavy rain created a crisis
a group of men were frantically working
to reinforce the poorly built south fork
dam
holding back the lake containing over 14
million cubic meters of water
john park an engineer working at the dam
had telegraphed
two emergency messages of warning to
nearby johnstown
which lay downstream directly in the
path of the bulging dam
his messages were sent and received
but they were never passed on because
johnstown had received so many other
false alarms about a possible dam break
but then on the afternoon of may 31 it
finally happened
at approximately 3 10 p.m the south fork
dam
completely collapsed releasing 20
million tons of liquid death
a massive 70-foot high brown mountain of
churning water with logs and debris
roared like niagara 14 miles down the
little river valley towards the
unsuspecting johnstown
by the time the town saw the rushing
wall of water it was too late
the result 2208 people were swept to
their deaths
making it one of the worst disasters in
american history
all because an urgent warning was not
passed
on did you know the bible talks about a
time when most of the world
ignored an urgent message of warning
stay with us friends we're going to
learn more on this edition
of bible answers live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
welcome listening friends to bible
answers live if you have a bible
question we
are live we invite you to call in with
our questions i see we have a few lines
still open
i know there's a couple people that are
holding and we're going to get to your
calls in just a moment
that phone number is 800-463-7200
that's 800-463-7297
and calling now good chance you'll get
your question on tonight's broadcast
we are also streaming if you want to see
what's happening here in the studio
then it's the doug batchelor facebook
page or amazing facts facebook page
and you'll see uh myself and pastor ross
here in the studio and i am
doug batchelor my name is john ross good
evening friends and pastor doug
let's start the program with prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
time to open up your word and study
together this evening and as we always
do when i ask your presence to be with
us
and lord we pray that as we study
together we might be drawn closer to you
be with those who are listening wherever
they might be we ask us in jesus name
amen amen well pastor i can open the
program talking about this terrible
disaster that occurred back in
1889 i guess uh john johnstown
flood in pennsylvania
2209 is what the count is that i'm just
looking at these figures here
that's a you know terrible tragedy and a
hike
a death toll and yet so many more lives
could have been saved
had people received the warning there
was enough time i guess for people to
escape and get to higher ground but they
ignored the warning almost like the
titanic
with the icebergs yeah they probably
would have had 20 minutes
to get to high ground and virtually
everyone could have made it
but um the officials that got the
telegraph message said oh not that again
you know we've heard them cry wolfe so
many times
and you can't help but wonder if all of
the times now in the
recent years you know people are saying
oh we've figured out the date for the
second coming
and there's been so many false alarms
you might say
that to go back hundreds of years people
predicting it and
you know a little more recently there
have been a few personalities that
predicted the
second coming and of course those
predictions failed
that now when christians say you know
look at what's happening in the world
maybe these signs
are harbingers of the coming of the lord
soon now no one knows exactly when jesus
is very clear about that
that no one knows the day and the hour
but christ did say
when you see these signs these things
begin to happen
lift up your heads for your redemption
draws near
and so we can know when it's near and
that's why he gave us these signs
and he wants us to prepare and
to get to higher ground you might say
and that would be
the high ground of the cross we need to
make sure that we're in a saving
relationship with the lord because
think about it friends this life is
nothing compared to eternity why would
you sacrifice
eternal life and needlessly
suffer the consequences in the lake of
fire when you could be forgiven
this is the stakes are too high and so
i can also think about in the bible
jesus said his coming would be like in
the days of noah
where noah pled with people for 120
years
but they didn't listen and then in the
days of lot
lot went and pled with his family and
said arise out of this place god's going
to destroy this place and
they mocked and you wonder is that
happening again
in the world you know we do have a book
and it's got an intriguing title it's
called the last night on earth and
pastor i was just thinking about that
one day there will be
the last night on earth and uh what does
the bible say about the second coming of
christ and more importantly how can we
prepare
our hearts and our lives and this
preparation is not gathering up food
for some coming catastrophe rather it's
the preparation of the heart
so we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks if you'd like to get
our free book tonight it's called the
last night on earth
the number to call is 800-835-6747 that
is the resource phone line
and again ask for the book that's called
the last night on earth and if you have
a bible question our phone line here to
the studio is 800-463-7297
we've got charles listening in florida
charles welcome to the program
hey thank you pastor doug pastor ross
thanks
my question is uh oh like always i've
called many times before i've got
lots of questions um
my question is this when the uh when
satan's followers the demons
once they seen that what uh satan had
done by
having jesus christ you know seeing
jesus crucified on the cross
with is it possible that if they had
repented that god would have accepted
them back or are they lost forever
you know the bible seems to indicate
good question you know
no one wants to think about anyone a
human or angel
being forever lost and satan's angels
were deceived
they i i believe that satan's angels had
a long period of probation just like
humans do in our lives
at where they saw both sides of the
issue and they still kind of aligned
themselves with satan
and at some point they grieved away the
holy spirit
and they they have committed the
unpardonable sin now they're still alive
the bible tells us that they are
reserved in everlasting chains of
darkness
and even the angels when they saw jesus
they said have you come to torment us
before the time they know their time is
coming
revelation 12 satan says he knows he has
a short time
they know their day of judgment is
coming but
i think that because they know that
their destiny is fixed
that they're they're just bent on taking
as many with them as they can
so i don't believe there's forgiveness
for the fallen angels
you know we'd have a book that talks
about um well we actually have several
i'm looking at one year past today it's
called satanic chains
which talks about this time period that
you read about in revelation 20 where
the devil is
cast into the bottomless pit what is
that all about
obviously the angels and the devil have
passed the point of of no return
but we'll be happy to send anyone who
wants to learn more about this
event that the bible speaks of is
happening in the future it's called
satan in chains
we'll be happy to send you that book the
number is 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the book
called satan in chains
we've got george listening from new
jersey george welcome to the program
uh thank you how both are you doing
tonight all right doing great thank you
okay i had a question about the uh
identity of those in the resurrection
how is the identity of the person
retained for the well all of us that die
and you know they're resurrected seeing
that the
dead i guess don't exist or they're
sleeping in a sense according to
scripture
how is their identity retained it seems
like it would be difficult
to have the identity retain things that
they're non-existent during that
intermediate state and those that
believe that the soul exists consciously
i think they have a better way of
explaining
identity but i've never really heard it
explained
in accordance with the view that you
have about the dead sleeping
you see what i'm trying to get at there
the idea yes i think so you're just
wondering is there is it necessary to
have
a continuity of consciousness to have a
continuity of identity
is that a fair way to say it yep
perfect okay well if uh if a person goes
to sleep
now first of all the idea of people
sleeping in death it's not
my belief i think it's what jesus said
when lazarus died jesus said our friend
lazarus is asleep
and i go to wake him and paul speaking
of the dead he said you know those that
sleep in christ shall arise and
again it says many that sleep in the
dust of the earth will awake some to
everlasting life and some
to shame and everlasting contempt so
these are this is the terminology of the
apostles and jesus all through the new
testament
so if i go to sleep uh when i wake up
sometimes i might be disoriented for a
few moments but i haven't lost my
identity
it you know it's still there in modern
terminology you know what i might say
george is
um i've sometimes gone from country to
country
and i have to have you got couple things
if you run a computer you got what they
call software and hardware
our brains you would call software and
i've got all my programs and my software
today it's very convenient i can put
everything all the brains of my computer
can fit on a little device as big as my
fingernail it's amazing
little usb drive i can go to another
country
and plug that into their brand new super
computer
and all my programs run so god is giving
us new bodies
but he's taking the essence of who we
are and i don't know what god's
software storage looks like but you know
god knows everybody
if a person you know is is burnt to
death and their ashes are scattered in
the sea
god has no problem resurrecting them
they don't lose their identity
so whether it's a moment um or
and for the dead it may seem like just a
moment
a thousand years might go by uh you know
king david says he slept with his
fathers
and peter said even after the
resurrection david is dead and buried
this is acts chapter 2
and not ascended to heaven that means
from when david died about a thousand bc
to today's about 3 000 years but for
david
it's the next thing he knows is the
presence of the lord there's no
consciousness in death
so for a believer when they die the next
thing they know is the resurrection
and there's really no loss for them well
you know we have the example in the case
of lazarus where he was dead for four
days and jesus resurrected him
and when lazarus came from the grave he
had been dead
even decay began to sit in he knew who
he was
he knew who christ was so in the
resurrection he was
pre-loaded you might say with all of the
thoughts and the feelings and the
understanding that he had prior to his
death yeah and he makes no
i think george there's probably 12
resurrections in the bible
you could argue a couple of them and in
all those stories
nobody ever makes a comment about what
they saw during death
the best we know is they were
unconscious
well thank you and we do have a book if
you've not seen it it's called are the
dead really dead we'll send you a free
copy of that
anybody the number to call is eight
hundred eight 800-835-6747 this is one
of the amazing facts study guides it's a
great study it's called other dead
readily dead just ask for that and we'll
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks
we've got uh anthony listening in new
york anthony welcome to the program
yes good evening pastors evening uh my
question is coming from
john chapter 20 verses 22 and 23.
okay would you like me to read that for
the people listening yes please
okay this is speaking of after the
resurrection and jesus said in verse 22
of john 20
and when he said this he breathed on
them and said receive the holy spirit
if you forgive the sins of any they are
forgiven of them
if you retain the sins of any they are
retained
so my question is what does this
mean in the context of what christ is
speaking
and then can someone try what if
somebody were to try to use this to
justify
uh uh indulgences or something like that
or
just showing that the church has the
ability to
forgive or say somebody's sins are
forgiven or not forgiven or something
like that
what can we how can we understand this
well you're right the uh
the church the catholic church in
particular already does use this very
verse to justify
the giving away of indulgences you know
during the dark ages martin luther
protested they were selling
indulgences the first thing you'd ask
sometimes you
almost have to come at it backwards to
get the right answer
is jesus saying that humans forgive we
decide
who is saved and who is lost we decide
who is forgiven and not forgiven
no the bible says god and god only can
forgive sins that's mark chapter 2.
and so really the way that we are
involved in forgiving sins
is as we pass on the gospel
or neglect to pass on the gospel the
keys of life
are are distributed or not distributed
and so i think pastor ross looked like
he was going to say something
yes i was going to add to that pastor
you're right
the key to the kingdom isn't in the hand
of a priest
but in reality through what christ has
done it's in the reach of
everyone or anyone who chooses if we
believe
so in the work of evangelism in the work
of sharing our faith with others
we are helping people take hold of that
key
that brings everlasting life and so
there is a part that we have to play
jesus said that we have to preach and
teach take the gospel to all the world
as a witness to all nations so there is
a work and it's an important work it's a
life-saving work
the work of evangelism and preaching the
gospel yeah and i think also jesus is
emphasizing
for the disciples in a similar passage
he says whatever you bind on earth is
bound in heaven
he's saying that the the work of
spreading the gospel in the words of
life
is the power for people to find
forgiveness or not through neglect of it
or rejection of it that what they did on
earth
was going to have consequences in heaven
is i think a very important point
good question anthony and uh i don't
know we have we have a book on that we
almost thought to
yeah not on that person particularly but
uh it's an important question
uh we got jerry listening in dallas
texas jerry welcome to the program
hey pastors good evening hope your day
is going well
i i would like to give a little rebuttal
to charles question
and it's a kind of like praise to god if
i may
if not i'll go on with my original
question well if yeah if you make it
quick
okay um you know we serve a wonderful
god
and for some reason satan would have
been restored to his original position
if he had repented he did not require a
blood sacrifice
that's right sorry yeah then through the
cross of course
jesus did for us right
now you got a question too okay yeah
yeah my question is uh when jesus
is when he is second coming christ is
coming at the right hand of
power and we understand we understand
that to be god
where is the holy spirit mentioned in
that
well he is the most humble humblest
person of the godhead
is the holy spirit probably one of the
characteristics of the holy spirit
is as with god is omnipotent
he's omniscient and he's omnipresent
and so i believe the holy spirit being
god the spirit is everywhere and so
instead of saying where is the holy
spirit
it's almost better to say where is not
the holy spirit
god says whither can you flee from my
spirit i think it's psalm 137
whither can you flee from my spirit so
he said if you go to the bottom of the
ocean
it's there if you go to the outermost
parts of the earth it's there
so the real question is where is god's
spirit not
at he's everywhere and so no doubt the
spirit will be with the father
the father and son do seem to have a
geographic
place where they abide you know we pray
to our father in heaven
and jesus said i go to my father and
your father and see he seems like he's
got a body
that has a location whereas the spirit
is never confined to any particular body
you know the verse you're referring to
is psalms 139 verse
7 which talks about that you know pastor
when you think about the holy spirit can
be everywhere um it's not just talking
about our world
but surely the holy spirit is also
present throughout the universe
and we think about how big the universe
is so how big is god i mean it's
remarkable for when you think about it
there's
no place you can go where the presence
of god
cannot find you yeah you can't go where
you can't be
absolutely thanks for your call jerry we
got noah listening in illinois
noah welcome to the program
i know you on the air
yeah get real close to your phone hello
yeah if you're on speakerphone you might
get a little closer
thank you for having me pastor driving
pastor ross yeah
if you've got your radio on the
background it's going to confuse you
yeah you gotta turn off your radio in
the background because you're gonna hear
yourself and get confused
okay you're on can you hear me
yep okay
so i have some stomach issues and i want
to know if there's anybody in the bible
that has
like stomach digestive issues
when it comes to like digesting
digestion and all that yeah there's
probably a few people
that you can think of i know that um
paul said to timothy and pastor ross may
have already looked that up
you want to read that yeah first timothy
chapter 5 is 23
paul is writing a letter to young
timothy and apparently
he might have eaten something or got
some kind of a bug but he had an upset
stomach
we don't know the details but he was
telling him
the supposes it says no longer drink
only water
but use a little wine for your stomach's
sake and for your frequent infirmities
so apparently you had some stomach issue
and of course back
in those days you always wonder how
clean the water was that the people
the bacterial problems they get pretty
sick so um
almost like a medicine so yeah there's
one person that we know of in the bible
know
that had stomach problems and uh it also
says i think that
in proverbs he said don't eat too much
um honey it'll make your stomach bitter
honey sweet in the mouth eat too much
honey you'll vomit
and who was it that had digestion
problems because you eat a book
that's right john and ezekiel i think
both eight books they tasted good in
their mouth but they were bitter and
they're
revelation 10. so don't eat any books
by the way a little amazing fact there
was a ethiopian king
holly salasi i think no that was the one
before him
and he really believed that whenever he
had a stomach ache if he would eat pages
of the bible it would make him feel
better
but when he got much older i think he
was about 70 he got really sick
and he ate a whole book of the bible and
then he died
but so that's not the best thing to do
all right well thanks for your call uh
next quarter that we have is uh
hubert listening from florida hubert
welcome to the program
hi thank you thank you and your question
um it says in latter times
that in the in the flock
there will be ravenous wools in sheep's
clothing
that will scatter the flock
um can you tell me who the the flock is
and who might be these ravenous wolves
yeah i think you're actually combining
two verses but you're correct
uh one is paul speaking of i think it's
in the book of acts he says after my
departure
ravenous wolves will come in not sparing
the flock and then jesus is the one who
said
that you've got false teachers that are
like wolves in sheep's clothing
well the flock is the church it would be
those who have accepted christ in his
word
and they're his people and the wolves
well satan as the bible says satan
himself
masquerades as an angel of light and
that's second corinthians 11 i believe
and so satan and his representatives
will pretend to be
christians will pretend to be christian
leaders
but they're taking advantage they're
they're not wanting to save the flock
they're devouring the flock like wolves
there are some what we call prosperity
preachers out there and all they do is
they talk about
how god is going to make the flock rich
if they send
their ministry money and then these guys
live
usually extravagant lives living off the
sheep
and that's an example of wolves that are
devouring the substance of the sheep
pastor ross
yeah a few verses that pass that i've
mentioned you've got matthew chapter 7
verse 15
where jesus actually says beware of
false prophets who come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly they are
ravages wolves
and in matthew 24 11 it says then many
false prophets will rise up and deceive
many
so there is a warning that we find in
the bible that in the last days in
particular there would be these false
prophets or false preachers
that would deceive a large number of
people and the bible warns us we've got
to test everything by the bible
to the lord to the testimony do they
speak according to this
oh we got another caller frank is
listening in uh the netherlands frank
welcome to the program
yes hello hi thank you for calling
hi um i had a question about the
jesus uh when he was on the cross was he
left by the holy spirit
good question i believe that when christ
before even got to the cross by the way
i know it's not the netherlands but i
was supposed to be in norway i think
next week and the cursed uh
flights have all been canceled so i'm
sorry i'm not coming to your neck of the
woods
um anyway back to your question
when jesus was in the garden of
gethsemane and he prayed the third time
father not my will thy will be done i
believe that god withdrew his presence
from christ
and jesus experienced complete
separation from god now that would be
god the father and the spirit
and i think that
just like a lost person he paid the
penalty for sin
as though a person had grieved away the
holy spirit he
looked at the second death he kind of
experienced
facing the second death as the lost will
so i don't know what pastor ross
thinks but yeah the spirit is everywhere
but i don't think christ had the spirit
in him at that point
yeah we got the verse in matthew 24 46
where jesus cries out my god my god why
is thou forsaken me
now we know that when jesus is on the
earth he laid aside his divinity
so he went through life the same way we
would have to go through life he was
dependent upon the holy spirit to reveal
things to him
and if he cries my god my god why has he
forsaken me
it would appear that the holy spirit was
pulled back or withdrawn
for a period of time when jesus was
bearing the weight of the sins of the
world
yeah and then i'm just thinking about
that prophecy in isaiah 53
where um it says let me just i'm looking
to see if that word forsaken is in there
um i mean you've got psalm 22 verse 1
which of course jesus was quoting from
where he said my god my god why is that
forsaken me
yeah i'm still looking here so yeah i
mean he did pay the price of sin
and bore the penalty remarkable thought
you know the righteous never need to
worry about being forsaken by god
because of what jesus did for them
whereas christ was forsaken yeah it says
he was numbered with the transgressors
and bore the sin of many
and so he was treated as a transgressor
and
i think the spirit was withdrawn see
david prayed take not thy holy spirit
from me
because that's what happens when a
person is lost
the bible tells us the spirit of the
lord left king saul
jesus i think experienced that same
lostness
friends i hope that helps frank don't go
away we're just taking a break
this is our halftime break got some
important announcements
we'll be back in just a moment with more
of your calls
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it
at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at afbookstore.com or by calling
1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit
kingdomsandtime.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides
a clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
[Music]
welcome back listening friends this is
bible answers live we're glad that
you've joined us
if you have a bible question just pick
up your phone give us a call 800
this is north america 800-463-7297
800-463-7297 that's 800 god says with
your phone calls
and we get calls from all over the world
lately and
you're we're also streaming if you want
to see visually what we're doing here in
in this studio this is actually a
preliminary studio about 50 feet from
where pastor ross and i are sitting
uh there's a beautiful studio being
constructed where we're going to be
having a bigger set for bible answers
live and be able to even have guests
that come in and join us and
it'll be on network television and so
you'll be
listening to and being able to watch and
participate in bible answers live
now just a little confession if you're
looking on the monitor
it's 150 degrees in sacramento today so
i'm wearing shorts i just want my
my skinny legs were sneaking out from
under the table i'm sorry
but um anyway it's still warm
[Laughter]
no pasta everyone's going to go to
facebook that's that was a great comment
yeah they're going to want to see what's
going on over there
all right all right i'm doug match with
pastor ross in case you haven't met us
before
we've got diane listening not far away
in sacramento diane welcome to the
program
thank you gentlemen for helping us with
these questions we have
really appreciate it what my question
entails
is exodus 2 12 where
moses it said look this way and that
when he was going to murder the
egyptians
and and then he appears in the
transfiguration
which i'm wondering um you know if he
was forgiven
for that uh since he appeared there
and then jesus is on the cross and says
he forgives his murderers
right and of course the only sin
it says in the bible is blasphemy of the
spirit
and what my question is is would this
mean
that committing suicide is forgiven
since it's a murder of of a person
and the reason why i'm concerned about
this is there's
theologians who really seem to disagree
on this
that you know these people are not
forgiven
or they are forgiven and there's a lot
of
people in the christian community that
are very concerned about this
are their loved ones right forgiven are
they in heaven
very good question yeah well stated and
it is a difficult question
uh diane there um moses you know he
committed murder and yes of course he's
forgiven
we do see him in heaven david committed
murder
and we'll see him in heaven and um
you know and then there's others that
apparently were forgiven even manasseh
who
not only committed murder and murdered
prophets but you know he was involved in
child sacrifice
but he repented humbled himself greatly
and it says the lord heard his prayer
so you may even see manasseh in heaven
uh you got people like nebuchadnezzar
who turned to the lord and you look in
chapter four and he had the blood of
whole armies on his hands so
um now the question about suicide since
it's in a category of self-murder
you know in most cases in the bible when
a person commits suicide
uh if the last act of your life is
self-murder
it doesn't bode well now i think you
need to be very careful about
saying that a suicide is always an
automatically lost
because there are sometimes i think
exceptional circumstances
in the case of samson he really died by
his own hand
but we expect to see him in heaven
according to hebrews chapter 11 because
i think they were getting ready to kill
samson and so the last act of his life
was
he said well if i need to take out the
enemies of god's people
and die in the process i'll do it so it
was something of a
sacrifice as opposed to a suicide um
but i've known people who've just lived
godly lives and in their last illness
their minds were not clear either
through medication or
some chemical imbalance and they did
something reckless in a moment of pain
or discouragement it took their life
and i i'm i doubt that god is going to
judge
their whole life of service by an
impulsive act at the end
that was because of either some mental
handicap
or chemical you know imbalance or some
medication
uh that they were on so um i i think
god's gonna look at the tenor of their
lives and show mercy in those cases
so i think we need to be very careful
now when you're talking about suicide
every now and then i'll get some young
person who's discouraged and they
they just want to give up on life so
i've talked to you know
some girl she said my boyfriend broke up
with me and i want to die will god
forgive me if i kill myself i'm saying
oh heavens you've got your whole life
before you
and so you don't ever want to tell a
young person in a situation like that
well yeah god will forgive a suicide
because that sends the wrong signal to
them
and at the same time you have parents
or someone who they got a loved one or
some relative that took their life and
they are they saying is there no hope
and you can't leave those people
thinking there is never any hope in
those circumstances so
it is a difficult subject but in most
cases
i would say that if the last act of a
person's life is self-murder
and if you cannot be saved without faith
and hope
and suicide is usually an example of a
person that has lost hope and faith
that it typically is not going to end
well but there
are exceptions so hopefully that made
sense diane
well yes thank you very much for that
commentary pastor i really
appreciate it because it's like i said
there's a lot of
christians who are very concerned about
this subject and um
yeah it's a real concern it is a real
concern
well thank you good question and it's
probably something i think i've got an
article online i do
i wrote an article on that that's in the
inside report
if you go to the amazing facts website
and just search
a suicide i think that that article will
come up
it's not in a book yet though next
quarter that we have is chris listening
from florida chris welcome to the
program
yes hello pastors thank you for taking
my call
thank you get real close to your phone
yes uh i i have a question about
if there is a distinction between
physical human body and uh and the soul
because in in the gospel of mark it says
you know uh what good
does it is is it when
if the man gains the whole world and
loses his soul
yeah and i have some friends that
actually believe that the soul and the
physical body is the same so
what is your view on that well most of
the time you experience your physical
body
uh through your soul in other words if
you don't have the spirit of life
you don't experience your body most of
what we experience is in
you know god gave us the breath of life
he took adam from the dust of the ground
formed him formed his body breathed into
that body the breath of life he became
a living soul and so typically a soul is
the combination
of the breath of life from god and that
word breath of life is the word
spirit or is in hebrew
and greed it's a pneuma in greek that's
where you get the word
pneumatic or pneumonia and um
that spirit of life comes from god when
a person dies the spirit returns to god
who gave it that breath of life
the body returns to the earth as it was
and
the soul really stops you stop
experiencing life until the resurrection
when
god puts the spirit of who you are
your personality in that new body
with the spirit of life so
i don't know if i just made that more
complicated or not you know i think
sometimes the word soul is used in the
bible to represent the mind
our character our thoughts um obviously
when a person dies they no longer think
uh the bible says they're like they're
sleeping
but when a person is asleep and they
awake you know they sort of
ready to go so in the resurrection we
will have
our thoughts our character we will
recognize one another
so the soul would yes refers to the body
a living being but it also
i think as a deeper application
referring to the mind the essence of our
character who we are
so thank you chris uh you know i think
that lesson we have on are the dead
really dead talks about what is a soul
absolutely and we'll send this to anyone
who asks the number is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the uh study
guide is called are the dead really dead
and we'll get that in the mail and send
it to you
if you're outside of north america we
encourage you to go to the amazing facts
website and you'll be able to read the
study there
we also have a website called
deathtruth.com that has a lot
additional resources and even some
sermons available
so we encourage you to take a look at
that you know past ross we often offer
the
study guide are the dead really dead but
we have another free book
at our website called spirits of the
dead
and i think it also talks about the
nature of the soul
and they'll find that at the amazing
facts website called spirits of the dead
by joe cruz
next quarter that we have is uh valerie
listening in georgia valerie welcome to
the program
hi thank you for taking my call thank
you for calling
okay my question is about enoch i only
learned recently that there was a book
of enoch but it's not included in most
translations
apparently because it's not inspired
word of god
i don't know if that's correct but my
question is
did enoch really see into heaven
as he describes in the book of enoch
which was very descriptive
and it were the were the angels that he
described the
the good angels or the fallen angels all
right well the book of enoch
um is actually it's quoted it it was
probably written during the babylonian
captivity when the jews were in babylon
to help
them retain their identity they called
it the book of enoch but
it was not written by enoch because if
you think about it for a book
of enoch who lived before the flood to
somehow
be in the hands of the jews it would
have had been passed on from
enoch to noah to shem to abraham
to moses so forth i mean it's it's
pretty unlikely
you know that we don't even know if they
were writing back before the flood
they had such copious memories that you
know you don't really i think the first
time you hear writing mentioned is the
book of job he talks about writing with
a
pen a diamond pen in a rock or something
um but the book of enoch there
were some inspired statements in it that
jude quoted from
um you know a lot of people in america
quote from ben franklin but ben
franklin's not part of the bible
you know if you say early to bed and
early to rise make you healthy wealthy
and wise well that's probably a good
idea
you might a bible writer or someone
might quote that i think even paul
quoted from some
greek poets and he quoted some
snippets of truth doesn't mean all greek
poets were telling the truth
or that it should be part of the bible
so jude quoted from the book of enoch
but the book itself
is not all inspired but there were some
passages in there
that jude said were inspired
i hope that makes sense yeah
okay thank you yeah so you know it's
it's still an amazing book
uh i do think there's some theological
problems in the book of enoch
that if i remember right but
the part that jude quoted is good all
right thanks for your call valerie we've
got mike listening in missouri mike
welcome to the program
hey how you guys doing great
every day is like the one before lately
okay um i don't know anyway
my question is in reference to matthew
chapter 9
verse 2 and my question is
was jesus trying to appease that's the
main word of my question
the crowd by forgiving the man's sin
first because
the crowd said god thought that he
deserved to be paralyzed
because of his own personal sins or
because of the sin of his parents
yeah this is talking about the paralytic
and you find this
in matthew 9 you find it in mark 2 you
find the story in luke 5.
this man that is let down through the
roof he's obviously
in bad shape physically because he has
to get carried by four men to get to
jesus
so he's totally paralyzed he can't walk
or use crutches and you would think the
first thing jesus would do is take care
of the outer problem
but christ was showing a priority by
healing
his physical his spiritual problem first
anytime christ healed a person
physically
it is always temporary even lazarus
being raised from the dead which is a
very powerful healing when you think
about it
he was raised from the dead until he got
old and sick and died again
so every physical healing is temporary
jesus healed people physically because
he loved them to relieve them but to
also show god's ability to heal them
forever
through forgiveness so with this man he
got the priorities in order where he
said first your sins are forgiven
and i think that man was very happy just
to hear his sins were forgiven
but then that the crowd might know that
he had power to do the bigger miracle
says which is harder forgiving sin are
telling them to rise up and walk
but so you'll know that i have power on
earth to forgive sins
he said to the sick man take up your bed
and walk
so the main reason jesus did that
miracle is to show
that he can heal us spiritually whatever
your sins are friends
jesus can save you from your sins and
forgive your past
sins your guilt that's the main thing
mike in that story okay
all righty thanks appreciate that good
question
we've got uh joel listening in uh north
carolina joel welcome to the program
hi pastors how are you guys doing good
we're glad you called
thank you um i have a question about
first corinthians chapter
13 verses 8 through 10.
okay would you like me to read that um
if you don't mind please not at all
love never fails but whether there are
prophecies they will fail
whether there are tongues they will
cease whether there is knowledge it will
vanish away
for we know in part and we prophesy in
part but when that which is
perfect is come then that which is in
part is done away
is that the parts yeah that was the part
um my
the one part that i'm a little confused
by is
i've asked a couple of people in my life
about
this verse and they were saying that
the gifts that are listed
in verse 8 such as tongues in prophecy
are not for today because they say that
when completeness comes in verse 10 that
means that
they said the people that i've talked to
have said that means
the first coming of jesus and i've been
reading
and meditating on this verse recently
and i was wondering
if it would make sense since first
corinthians is written after the second
coming the first coming of jesus if what
paul is talking about in first
corinthians about
when completeness comes is the second
coming of christ
you know i would and i think that you
and i are on the same page that we agree
the gifts of the spirit did not cease
uh after the days of the apostles i i've
got some pastors that i
am friends with of other churches and i
would respectfully disagree with them
they think that all of the supernatural
gifts of prophecy and
healing and tongues all pass away with
the apostles
but crisis and i'm trying to remember in
ephesians where
pastor ross you said but these things
are for the
edification of the church and tell the
fullness
of all things and so
the gifts of the spirit are still
necessary
all the way through the history of the
church christ told the apostles you will
speak with other tongues
he said these miracles that i've done
greater things than these will you do
i've seen incredible miracles of healing
now i've not seen you know somebody
missing an arm have it pop back into
place
or a person that was born blind suddenly
see but i think that god's spirit tends
to come in waves through history
and i think it's a lack of faith to
believe that before the second coming
the climax of all history that god is
not going to
pour out his spirit and demonstrate
miracles as he had before
so joel is is that making sense
yes it is thank you very much pastors
all right thank you and
we do have a book about the holy spirit
you have a good night and we'll be happy
to send you that book called life in the
spirit
the number to call for that is just
after the book called 800-835-6747 in
the spirit we'll get that in the mail
you know and we have if joel is
listening we actually also have a book
called
understanding tongues where i talk more
about spiritual gifts
like speaking in tongues and how though
those gifts are sometimes misunderstood
all the gifts of the spirit are still
needed by the church including the gift
of tongues and prophecy
and healing so thank you appreciate your
call
joel all right the verse you're
referring to i think pastor
is first corinthians 5 that talks about
these gifts and it says
that the church might receive
edification or be built up
uh in these different gifts i think it's
i'm also looking for one that says and
the unity of the faith
if we type that in here
unity of the faith see if i can find it
yeah here it is ephesians 4 13
until we all come it talks about the
need of the gifts of the spirits
till we all come to the unity of the
faith and the knowledge of the son of
god to a perfect man
the measure of the stature of the
fullness of christ it says we need the
gifts until we're there
we're not there yet so the church will
always need those gifts
all right next caller that we have is uh
cassandra listening from california
cassandra welcome to the program
hi thank you thank you and your call
your question rather
my question pertains to actually hebrews
26 where it talks about deliberately
going on spinning
and the backstory to that is that i
was a young age raised in church so i
had a pretty good idea
right and wrong but when i became an
adult i didn't make
the right choices and so now
i'm trying to figure it all out again
and i'm like do i get baptized again am
i
am i can i even be forgiven because of
that one
you know i can just tell listen i'm not
i'm not god or the holy spirit but i can
tell listening to your voice
that the holy spirit's working in your
heart and of course you can be forgiven
that verse in hebrews 10 26 that says if
we sin willfully after we receive the
knowledge
of the truth remains no more sacrifice
for sins
but a certain fearful looking forward to
of judgment and people say well i knew
the truth and i turned away
that means there's no more forgiveness
what paul is saying there is if a person
continues to live
in a life of sin after they know the
truth
god cannot save them if they persist in
living in a life of sin so
i think i'm hearing you say cassandra
you are wanting to turn back
to jesus and live a new kind of life of
course you can be forgiven
the bible says that whosoever comes to
him
that jesus christ died for sinners you
know
peter knew the truth and he denied
christ and god forgave him
david knew the truth he was filled with
the spirit and he gotten to
be backslid in a major way with adultery
and lying and murder
and god forgave him and so
i think that hebrews 10 26 is talking
about a person who persists in a life
of sinful living after they know the
truth god can't do
anything more for them if they persist
in that life
it says yeah if we sin willfully that
means if we're continuing
in high-handed sin against god saying
we're just not going to do what you want
what more can god do if a person makes
that choice
so fortunately you're alive and i
believe the door of mercy is open
and god is in inviting you he says look
jesus loves you and
he's eager to save you he wants you to
come to him
you know we do have a book cassandra we
want to tell you about it's called
three steps to heaven it's one of my
favorite and it just talks about
the steps that we need to take to come
back to god if we've drifted away
uh what does it mean and we'll be happy
to send this to you for free
all you have to do is just call our
resource phone line that number is
800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book called
three steps to heaven
and we'll be happy to send it to you and
uh there's
always hope especially in the holy
spirit speaking to the heart of someone
and they they feel the prompting of the
spirit we want to
encourage people to make that positive
decision for christ
thank you for your call we've got uh
andrew listening from overland park
kansas andrew welcome to the program
hey how you guys doing good thanks for
calling
yeah so my question is um i wonder if
you can explain
the leviathan in the behemoth and
um the bible says if two more people are
together uh talking about god uh
he's there would that include something
like this like over the internet too
yeah i think so i think that uh if
if we're together in god's name that
he's in our presence and
even through the medium of radio or
television i think god
through his spirit he can of course be
with us
but back to your question about
leviathan and behemoth these are two
different creatures that are mentioned
in the bible
leviathan is some kind of a huge
sea creature but when you get to the
book of job
the leviathan ultimately starts sounding
like
it is the devil some of the descriptions
that are in the latter part of
the book of job and says you know who
can pierce his scales
and it's almost like he's that dragon
because the the book of job begins with
satan
the accuser of the brethren he's
accusing job at the end
job's righteousness vindicates god
and the leviathan is sort of overthrown
but then there's another reference to a
creature the behemoth
and you know both of those terms today
are used to describe
a really big land beast or really big
sea beast
i went diving with our family in the
caribbean and we saw the whale sharks
and they call them the leviathans of the
deep kids
they're huge a behemoth some wonder if
it was a
dinosaur because it it's got big legs
but it says it's got a thick tail it's
not a hippo or a uh
elephant pastor ross is from africa so
he can speak to that
yeah it's kind of interesting the
description given it apparently it
lived in a marshy area it reeds but it
says it's
its legs are just like seeded trees and
its
tail is is ginormous well we don't have
any
animals today that have big strong legs
and a big strong tail
so ed lives in a marshy area in each
reed so some have thought this could
be referring to a dinosaur that lived
before the flood and
uh was destroyed with the flood um so
yeah that is an interesting race yeah
it's still a mystery for most bible
scholars but uh
i think it's one of the places where we
can speculate a little bit
hey thank you for your question we sure
appreciate that andrew and now we
don't have time to do justice for we see
robert and claudia irene laura
evil craig please give us a call next
week god willing we're going to be here
the way the world's going
i think we're going to be here again
next week and answering your questions
quick announcements amazing facts is
going to be doing a global evangelistic
program
on prophecy called revelation now
starts october 26th be watching for
details your church can be involved
in doing evangelism for your community
online
revelation now coming and friends in the
meantime stay close to jesus
and check out the amazing facts thank
you for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your bible even
better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay
california
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability
and global economic meltdown these are
the images people generally associate
with the tribulation
and the day of the lord but did you know
the bible speaks about another day of
the lord
just before the great judgment day
amazingly
imprinted on the very fabric of time
itself is a 24-hour period called the
sabbath
that was meant to forever be a time of
restoration for every human being
a day the entire world is largely
forgotten
you'll be surprised to learn how this
special day of the lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast
the seal of god and the great final
tribulation
it's all contained in this new
eye-opening dvd series called
the last day of prophecy to order
call 800 530
or visit afbookstore.com
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org
at aftv.org you can enjoy video
and audio presentations as well as
printed material
all free of charge 24 hours a day seven
days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling 1-844-215-7000 that's
1-844-215-7000
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800 835
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org